Ucrania lo alerta si la artillería rusa
golpea La Represa de la planta
hidroeléctrica de jacofka la magnitud
del desastre sería dimensiones
desproporcionadas devastando el
suministro de agua en gran parte del sur
dejando la planta nuclear de zaporilla
sin agua de refrigeración y podría
arrasar incluso con la reñida región de
gerson y al norte de la anexionada
crimea O volar la central hidroeléctrica
causaría problemas significativos para
ambas partes entonces lo que sí estamos
viendo Es como Rusia Está tratando de
disminuir la capacidad energética de
Ucrania de que ya se está acercando el
invierno y en este sentido obligará al
gobierno de selenski a sentarse a
negociar una salida política al
conflicto el gobierno ucraniano tiene
que decidir si manda esa energía
eléctrica de los hogares ucranianos o si
es energía eléctrica se va hacia las
armas según las autoridades ucranianas
las tropas rusas ya habrían minado la
rep para evitar así la contraofensiva de
kiev
Moscú niega las acusaciones al tiempo
que ha comenzado a evacuar a miles de
civiles de gerson señalando que las
tropas ucranianas pretenden recuperar
terreno a través de métodos de guerra
prohibidos
era preocupante pero cada día lo era más
pero pues pusimos hasta el último
momento con la esperanza de que se
calmara
la guerra parece ahora librarse también
en el plano energético el ministro de
energía de Ucrania aseguró que entre el
30 y el 40% de la infraestructura
eléctrica del país habría sufrido graves
daños por los constantes ataques del
kremlin muchos hospitales ya están
sufriendo cortes de luz y algunos
ciudadanos se apresuran a reunir madera
para calentarse ante el inminente